GÉRARD POIRIER, comédien
s'éteignent, jusqu'à ce que
mes mauissent plus
de douleur, jusqu'à ce que
ma mémoire devienne confuse. Je.
- C'est un grand comédien
En 60 ans de carrière,Gérard Pé
une multitude de personnages
au théatre, à la téléviaucoup
se couviendront du
Curé Folbèche dans "Les
Plouffe" de Gilles Carle.
- Lâche la gi ce que ti ce que .
- De Tancrède dans
"Le Parc des braves";
- C'est votre avenir qui se
décideutez un peu!
- Ou du notaire Cyprien
dans "Le Temps d'une paix".
- C'est plus tranquille que
vous l'abbé, hein.
- Touche à tout,
il a aussi pra publicité.
- C'est pour ça qu'ils portaient
des casques?
- Plus récemment, en 2011,
il a tdans "Henry", un court mée
de Yan England, qui a obtenu
une nomination aux oscars
en 2013.
- Qu'est-ce que tu fais ici?
- Les réactions à son d
sont nombreuses.
FRANCOISE FAUCHEnne
- Je dois dire que ce décès
me touche beaucoup. Le Québec
un homme aussi d'une grande,
grandet moi,
je perds un frère.
MONIQUE MILLER, comédienne
On dit souvent ça quand les gens
t, je l'ai déjà dit que
je l'aimais. Alors. Donc...
il y a d'autres personnesui dirt
un homme très généreux et
un grand acteur, surtout.
(applaudissements)
- En 2007, l'homme qui aura
marqué l'imaginaire québécois a
du Québec pour l'ensemble
de son oeuvre.
Ici Daniel Kadjo,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.